God bless you man just go ahead and get
in the car and make it home safe man
how good he feels right now
Lee syat is like I [__] took this
[__] down make it home safe buddy yeah
let's get that guy oh my God how is
there not a call to a welfare line can I
tell you something too because I love
Joey Diaz but he was actually like a
virus to that man like do you know what
has happened to Lisa's party he lost 150
pounds not an exaggeration
150 pounds he's like three of Joey like
he just totally has like blossomed look
at him oh my god dude he looks oh yeah
he looks good he looks exactly like the
guy we just saw in the last video dude
uh holy [__] look at him congrats to Lee
yeah Joe even like you're not doing well
enough Lee you need another couple 2 000
milligrams dude at least remember they
were wearing floaties I've never seen
somebody so high
and here's the thing Lee couldn't say
anything so he would be like I'd be like
he'd go yeah I was like are you all
right he's like and he could let he
forget to like click he would just sit
there snoring sitting down like
like snoring in his seat and then Joey's
like look at this [__] idiot yeah
he's like you know what he does all day
he watches Sports Center I hear his
phone goes
get your [__] [__] together I'm like
you are crippling this man
SportsCenter is all he can handle he's
working at an Enterprise Rental nowadays
he's [__] doing good
wow yeah it'd be there should be a
documentary one day made on Joey and Lee
and like a coming back together park by
a lake is this them recently that might
be an old picture it was nothing like
those two they were like uh who was a
better name a better comedy what this is
like though this is like this is like
the um the the guy on the left Lee gets
locked up in prison with the veteran you
know the guy that's been locked up
that's what their relationship was like
is what you're going to do all right you
stay away from the blacks you mind your
business you shower when I shower and
like and then you eat this [__] yeah
yeah it's just like in another dimension
yeah Brothers 84 ounces of uh Alfredo so
he would melt his brain unreal he would
melt his brain dude what was the time
one of my favorite times ever when I got
there there was okay look at that
[__] pillow somebody made have you
done have you seen the one have you seen
the one on uh um where Lee
is a like he falls asleep alone on
on the show yeah I think he's like he's
working it and then he's like and he
comes to he's like [__] like he just
it's it's I've watched it he's so
[__] high that he falls asleep and
wakes himself up and he's like I don't
even know what's happening man I don't
know if he's like he's streaming or
something like on Twitch I don't know
what but it's on YouTube and it's it is
it's so amazing it's like Lee the best
one time I went in and there was a
squeal in the headphones when I went in
yeah I was like Lee there's some
feedback or something by the end two and
a half hours later this Lee was like
this
he was the squeal yeah and we had gone
full [__] Circle yeah kicked that
mulee look he looked like this and
listen listen to the audio
he's broadcasting right now
oh damn dude
[Laughter]
get out of his mind dude
that's a good place and that's just that
is just if Joey is really close to you
this happens to you oh yeah well he
drugged me yeah he he [__] tricked me
and he's done it a couple times but the
worst one was in when I was in Miami and
he told me I was taking a 10.
and it just [__] it ruined two days
of my life right like two days of my
life
and
I I mean I was like just
I mean I was I was crying and [__] oh
yeah I was on a flight with him oh and
he's like oh you knew you knew you need
a you need a baby Xanax right now I'm
like I don't think this is the [__]
foreign
and I go dude and when I finally like
recovered I called her I was like what
the [__] dude he goes you needed it I go
I needed what you needed a reset and I
go why did I need one he's like it's
good for you I I saw what was happening
like this kind of thing always like that
what was happening he's like nah you
know you were getting you know a little
it's good now now you're ready to go I'm
like ready to go where am I going
yeah I'm at a gray house yeah man I'm I
was fine he was like no no no I did you
it was fun I go for who
he is dude he's the best salesman bro
yeah he just says like these little and
he says with his like little phrase it
was great yeah yeah and you're like
that's yeah I love you buddy yeah and
you look good now you get back to
chopping up vinegar and carrots and
you're like the [__] are you talking
about man what about that Owen Benjamin
all these [__] lost his mind huh
she'll say [__] like that it didn't
[__] just disappear dude unrest
on [__] real dude
look if that doesn't if that doesn't do
it I don't know what it does hope you
enjoyed that video and you can watch
another and you can watch this one you
can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one